asking me about the derivative and
whether it's right or not admittedly it
looks a little worse so just to not go
all the way looking to finish the
question but let's just do the
derivative and see if you can check your
answer with a triangle now you have two
things to notice here number one it's a
product it's this times that okay but
number two one of the factors of your
product requires chain all right okay so
make that a little more obvious remember
that sine sine cubed x is just kind of a
shorthand for saying sine X or cubes all
right
do you remember why we do that by the
way why do we put the three in the
middle that's weird yeah good so that
you don't call it this sign up just X
cubed which is a design function right
and you do with that another time so
therefore if that's science X or cubed
how are we gonna do this all right this
is you this is Ben let's give this guy
you test on your own work and see if
this check out okay just for the sake of
making sure your answers are right let's
do you work out the derivative because
we're gonna need it first part all right
there's two points of pearl so I want to
work out on you on the X that okay right
now this is sine X Oh cute so forget the
fact that it's a trig function right
just call that f of X F okay this is f
cubes and you're doing chain rule on it
right chain rule is different shape
inside differentiate the outside right
inside the outside what's the inside
here what's what's the F it's sign right
so therefore f dash the derivative of
the inside is cosine yes there's the
inside now you do the outside it's the
power of three so you bring the power
out the front and reduce the power by
one okay so if you're following all
right this is the you - that I'm off top
okay so I'm gonna keep that in mind and
now I'm gonna write my V u - u v - okay
this is just useful so you don't get
your head to twist it I know some of
we're doing this part because you're
doing it in line here for instance you
might forgot to put an extra cause on
from your be right so let's get this
again me is cause you - is this guy
right so I'm gonna cuz they're cause
here so cross square it's a three out
front
there's vu - so far so good
yeah is unchanged and then V - cause
turns into negative sign okay do you
have signed up for here to sign the form
I can take that out as you come in
factor because it is sine squared here
so I can take that out front
okay now this your derivative so at this
point you can know whether you're right
or not because I think most of you have
either this line or something different
now I'm actually not gonna stop there I
want my own my derivative to be as
simple as possible because in a minute
I'm gonna have to solve it so I can find
stationary points yeah so how can I
improve this well I've got all these
three functions playing around but a lot
of them right so I'm gonna try and
eliminate some now remember cos squared
sine squared
they're almost sort of interchangeable
in that you can use the plank McGorry in
a relationship to someone out for the
other if you want to get rid of one but
you don't have to you can do tan squared
later on if you want that's a big
legitimate but this is just one way to
simplify heads up so you can either get
rid of cos squared and turn it into one
minus sine squared or even over sine
squared and turn it into one minus cos
square which do you think we should go
with does it matter it doesn't really
matter because like I said right signs
bed cost rate this sort of
interchangeable so whichever you go with
should be a can I'll tell you which one
I'm gonna do it I'm um it's sorta it's
almost 50/50 I'm gonna get rid of the UM
I'm gonna get rid of the clothes okay
the reason why I'll tell you it's simple
is just cuz of that negative sign that's
it right on the number of people I've
seen right for the next line right if
they were getting rid of sine squared
and subbing out for one minus cos
squared right they'll write three cos
squared and then they'll write minus one
minus cos squared okay so they miss the
dal negative it's a very easy error to
not pick up so I just try to avoid
double negatives that's why I'm gonna
get rid of all so therefore my next line
will be sine squared three
okay so there's my derivative and I
think I'm happy with how simple that is
okay now if I want to solve this right
I'm sorry if I want to graph it I'm
going to need to find stationary points
from this I won't make you do points
inflection for obvious reasons okay but
even even sort without doing second
derivative you can see looking at this
thing have a lot of solutions okay there
are a lot of stationary points this
thing okay so I'm going to pause there
because now you know whether you got the
right ribbon or not and then let you
have a go graph